do you see that picture on the screen
that's a pencil and that's the lead on
the tip that's how much fentanyl it
takes to kill somebody by the way fentol
is the leading cause of death to people
ages 18 to 45 50 times stronger than
heroin 100 times stronger than morphine
over 150 people die on a daily basis
from this and what's most powerful about
it is you can potentially die from it by
just touching it there was a story done
recently where a lawyer from Cleveland
is sitting doing an interview with 60
minutes and they're saying why do you
have this person with gloves there he
said is because there's potentially the
risk of dying if you touch this thing
what's crazy about all of this stuff
it's FDA approved Patrick what do you
mean by this fanol is FDA approved the
santis while he's talking and there's a
debate going on tells the story of what
happened in Florida an 18-month-old baby
dies in Florida because they had an
Airbnb and the kid is crawling on the
floor and Report comes after this kid
dies that the baby had fentol in it
saying the fact that the previous people
that stayed at this Airbnb potentially
left fentol where the kid played with it
put it in their mouth like this died
fentanyl the amount of people that are
losing people due to fentanyl is
increasing on a regular basis and it's
an issue I want to get into because I
want to learn about it and I think you
need to as
[Music]
well so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into so
what is fentol fentol is a synthetic
opioid approved by the FDA for the use
of pain relief think about that it's FDA
approved marijuana has only killed one
person in the history of smoking weed
this is when you read the numbers this
you'll always find one person I think
she was 39 years old I don't know what
the numbers right now could be two but
the number I know is only one and it's
not FDA approved but uh fentanyl is FDA
approved the origin it was first
developed in 1959 and introduced in
1960s as a intravenous anesthetic it is
legally manufactured and distributed in
the US according to DEA . goov fentol
produces effects such as Euphoria pain
relief relaxation sedation confusion
drowsiness dizziness nausea vomiting
urinary retention and pupilary
constriction some of you are probably
watching this saying there's no way this
thing is FDA approv let me go Google it
you did that you're back okay did you
see it says FDA approv crazy right so
why is it FDA approved and how do they
view this like how does the FDA compare
fentanyl to Other Drugs the medical
advantage of fentanyl is that it goes
into effect much more quickly than
morphine and wears off much more quickly
for that same reason it's much more
addictive than heroin typically the high
of heroin will last an entire day after
shooting up but fentol wears off within
a few hours which means you need more of
it when it's gone fentol is cheaper to
produce dose Ford dose than heroin
wholesaling it at approximately 1/1 of
heroin's price by weight given that
fentol is approximately 50 times
stronger than heroin an equivalent dose
would therefore be 1300 or 1400 of the
wholesale price of heroin and you know
who said this nih.gov that's fentol for
you so how do drugs in us get classified
you know these different schedules we
keep hearing about schedule 1 2 3 4 a
schedule one drug is a drug with no
currently accepted medical use and a
high potential for abuse they are the
most dangerous drugs of all drugs
schedule with potentially severe
psychological or physical dependence
here's what's on that list heroin LSD
marijuana cannabis ecstasy methaqualone
and pyot now notice what's not in there
and as Fenton by the way later on we're
going to look at the data out of 100,000
people what percentage die when they use
it wa till you see the numbers of how
heroin compares to fentanyl but let me
continue schedule Two drugs with a high
potential for abuse would use
potentially leading to severe
psychological or physical dependence
these drugs are also considered
dangerous here we go number one vicadin
then cocaine then metamphetamine then
methadone Hydromorphone madine then you
got oxico then you have fentol then you
have dextrine arerol rlin fentol is in
the same category as rlin arerol and all
these other drugs but it's killing 150
people a day and marijuana schedule one
and it's only killed one ever somebody
that was 39 years old and they don't
even know if that's exactly due to
marijuana but that's the story everybody
talks about huh you know what's one of
the craziest numbers that came out on
what Co did to everybody this whole
loneliness uh epidemic that took place
where people don't have friends and
peers around them and they don't have
somebody to talk to and maybe you're
watching the say I'd love to talk to a
therapist but I don't want to go to a
doctor because anybody go to therapist
they're cons weird and I don't want to
be part of the weird Community I want to
go talk to somebody if you're someone
that wants to in a discret way talk to
therapist without anybody knowing better
help may be the perfect company for you
because you get to do this on your phone
video if you just want to do audio you
could and if you don't like the
therapist and it doesn't work out for
you they will simply replace it with
somebody else at no cost that's why
better help is the sponsor of today's
video better help can match you to one
of over 30,000 therapists they have in
their Network which gives you access to
wider range of expertise then may be
available in your area and to get
started all you need to do is fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs then you'll get match
with your therapist in most cases within
48 hours so look God knows how many
times we waste our hours doing things
that just not productive sometimes just
watch an Instagram go get one of the
therapists talk to them see how it works
out for you and if it does continue if
it doesn't at least you test it out for
yourself over 4 million people have use
better help to start living a healthier
happier life go to our sponsor
betterhelp.com valut for 10% off your
first month of therapy with betterhelp
and get match with a therapist who will
listen and help the link will be below
schedule three is a drug with a moderate
to l potential for physical and
psychological dependence schedule three
drugs abuse potential is in less than
schedule one and schedule Two drugs but
more than four so here we go
testosterone steroids anabolic steroids
ketamine and then you have Tylenol and
Codine schedule three schedule four
lowest level Xanax Soma Darvin daret
valume Adon twin ambian traod those are
some of the names on schedule form by
the way if I butcher the name I'm not a
doctor I'm just giving you some of these
drugs that are on this list so now when
we go a little bit closer and study this
recreational drug toxicity look at this
chart here at the top fentanyl 25% then
heroin then GHP then you have all of
these other things alcohol cocaine MDA
Codine you know goes all the way down to
DMT LSD look what's all the way at the
bottom marijuana yet marijuana is a
schedule one and fentol is a schedule to
whoever comes out with this list they're
probably not following what's going on
or there's other reasons for keeping
marijuana as one and fentol as 2 I don't
know maybe I'm just speculating let's
continue so then the question becomes so
drug dealers want to keep making money
why would they make a drug like this
that kills their customers isn't that
dumb do don't drug dealers want their
clients to live that's a valid question
so if fentol is so deadly why do drug
dealers use it to lace illicit drugs
according to nabarun das Gupta PhD
epidemiologist at the University of
Carolina at Chapel Hill studying opioids
done correctly lacing illicit drugs with
fentol often creates a return stream of
customers because fentol is considered
highly addictive this is why fentol is
often found in drugs like cocaine
counterfeit Xanax counterfeit adol or or
other drugs not classified as opioids
fentol is good for business if you lay
your addiction into it interesting so if
if in your life nobody's died from
fentanyl it's probably not something
that consumes your mind a lot you don't
think about it like why would I even be
thinking about fentol no one around me
died it's probably just a propaganda
look at this data here overdoses from
fentanyl when you look at this from 2018
to 2021 look at the average in 2018 it
was only 11% of drug poisoning deaths
but if you go to 2021 it's at what 44%
God knows where this thing's at today in
2023 we probably won't get those numbers
till second quarter of 2024 but I would
assume it's more than 44% today this
next data is very scary how much fentol
do we have in the US you ready the the
the government DEA announced the seizure
They seized over 379 million doses of
fentol in 2022 you know what that is
that's enough to kill the entire country
that's what they have today by the way a
fentol so now the next question is so
where does all this stuff come from
who's selling it to us who's producing
it who's making it and why domestic
black mark fentol comes from theft
fraudulent prescriptions and
distributions by patients Physicians
nurses physician assistants nurse
practitioners and pharmacist it's
estimated China is responsible for over
90% of a listed fentol found in the US
the majority of fentol is mass produced
in Mexico using chemicals from China
before being pressed into pills or mixed
with other counterfeit pills made to
look like Xanax adderal or oxy codin and
if you look at this chart right here
this will tell you where it's coming
from look at China to the left look how
many of it you see the blue it's going
from China to Blue Weare Canada it's
going from China to us China to Mexico
and then if you look it from Mexico
going back to India it's circulating you
can kind of see what's going on and
where it's being produced and what
states it's going to the most but China
is a party involved in this us is a
party involved in this cuz we're
receiving it then you got a little bit
of India you got some Mexico going on as
well you got to hear this one here in
China companies making precursor
fentanyl chemicals are subsidized by the
government and receive tax breaks what
tax breaks tax breaks according to who
investigative journalist and author Ben
westoff so how is this impact in America
this is the impact 42% of counterfeit
pills tested for fentol contain at least
2 milligram of fentanyl if you're not in
the fentol business you don't even know
what 2 milligrams means I don't know
what 2 milligrams means but check this
out if you look at this here the harm
reduction ohio.org you know what 2
milligrams is is 2,000 micrograms what
is 2 milligrams all the way at the
bottom death you can die from these 42%
counterfeit pills that they're testing
for fentanyl that contains 2 Mig of
fentol it's freaking insane if you think
about it so while we're going through
this we have to also be thinking about
when is it Spike like when did it all of
a sudden take off has this always been
around you maybe you're like I remember
partying 20 years ago I never knew about
this kind of stuff maybe even 10 years
ago what does it look like Pat here's
fentol uh data on the amount of people
uh dying overdosing on it from 1999 to
2022 look at the chart it's pretty flat
from 99 till when 2013 then slight
increase in 2014 15 16 then from 16
climbs all the way up to 2022 and now it
it is responsible for nearly 70% of all
drug overdoses death in
2022 and by the way as a parent if
you're wondering like who this impacts
the most it's 70% there but fentol
responsible for 80% of overdoses deaths
under 24 years old so if you got
somebody you got kids nephews cousins
peers this is really targeting the Youth
of America I remember earlier when I was
talking about heroin versus you know
fentol you're like well how many people
die per 100,000 use versus fentol of
heroin here's from statista this is from
CDC when you look at the colors baby
blue is heroin the yellow is
prescription opioids but red is
synthetic opioids which is what fentanyl
okay the blue out of 100,000 using it
4.1 die heroin yellow is 4.9 synthetic
opio it's fentanyl
17.8 this is not a small little chart
we're thinking about or looking at this
is massive the impact of fentanyl so if
you're watching this you're saying well
Pat what do I do about this if you if
you're if you don't have kids you got
friends educate them everything's about
education share this with your peers
with your brother with your sister get
everybody watching this two have your
kids watch this my kids are going to
watch this video to Lear for themselves
cuz they need to know this is real and
these things are happening when you and
I are not around think about how bad it
is today that even the Cartel caloa
Cartel from Mexico are noticing their
customers dying where they come out and
they say the following the calora cartel
the leading expor of fent on the US is
prohibiting the production and
trafficking of illegal opioids in his
territory after coming under increasing
pressure from the US law enforcement
cartel members say this is a Wall Street
Journal story from little over 2 weeks
ago is what we're talking about October
16 2 weeks ago the caloa cartel is
telling their people knock get off stop
producing this because it's affecting so
many people's lives and by the way China
how do we hold them accountable they're
producing 80 90% this and why are they
sending it to us why are they sending it
to Mexico and the Mexico makes it so who
is really the one to be held accountable
them I mean is this also impacting in
China as much as it is impacting us you
know some say Tik Tock is used as as a
way to
dumfer are they using these drugs to
kill our kids in America I mean they
definitely don't have a good reputation
of what they did the last three years
with coid and Wuhan lab and all the lies
what's their motive with this it's very
deceptive there's a lot of things I'm
skeptical about on what's causing with
us in China this is another thing that
China's got to be held accountable for
because they're producing this and
America's unfortunately being the
beneficiaries of losing their kids with
the drugs coming up to us through Mexico
the other question is if you're a parent
or if you're somebody that lost somebody
you're like how come this is not a
schedule one we a lot of weird people
right now that watch our content some
people could be watching this your
congressmen and women or Governors or
Mayors or you're involved in politics or
presidents why don't you put this in
schedule one why don't you categorically
put this and make it clear to everybody
so we all know why don't you make a
phone call and say hey any reason why
fentol is not a schedule one drug why is
it not and why is marijuana what are we
doing with these category how are you
processing your decisions when you're
doing this they also need to be held the
account of a state needs to be made with
that in 2018 one of the things Trump was
doing was he was he was proposing death
penalty if he distribute fentol could
that be something but no matter what it
is somebody selling fentol the crime for
Dad should be severe I don't know about
death penalty but it should be severe
because practically this much usage of
it could potentially kill anybody when
it comes down to China this could be a
Revenge thing that China is doing
because when you think about China's
history up until 1997 they were part of
the British colony they had like a 150e
contract because back in 1839 I think
they had two Opium Wars because uh the
Brits wanted the tea and this was one of
their ways of getting a bunch of people
addicted to Opium and and I think 90 out
of 300 million people of China's
population was addicted to Opium so
maybe this is one way of them getting
revenge who knows maybe I'm speculating
a little bit too much but China needs to
be held accountable on what it's doing
to America I think it is something to
question it is something that as a
president whoever is taking a leite next
that conversation needs to be had and
there needs to be a bit of a level of
accountability for someone to put on
them so again whatever you do you got
kidss peer siblings make sure everybody
watches this video and if you got value
out of it give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel if you like videos like
this we did something about big pharma's
biggest secret if you've never watched
it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye